welcome everybody
um so jihyo I'm going to start with you
and I hope I'm saying y'all's names
right and if I don't I'm sorry I'm
texting
um as as the leader of the group um can
you tell us how twice came together
[Music]
the 12 came together through an audition
program called 16. oh awesome oh I was
on an audition show
[Laughter]
so wait to all of you what are some of
your favorite things to do or to eat
like when you visit the US
um
I'm so excited to know what she just
said
[Music]
thank you
so she said the first thing is that she
loves being able to see once face to
face
and she actually likes talkies
[Music]
I'm into that
I'm into that I'm all right well Mama
how about you
yeah
she likes we know the grocery stores
here yeah
Raven at the grocery store I love okay
so Deion how about you
I like hamburger
yeah
and chocolate yeah
potato okay
pasta
I found my sister in the group okay okay
how about you too you what do you love
doing them
um I love pasta and pizza I love that
Italian food I like it okay how about
you John Young
[Music]
she loves looking at like the landscape
and seeing all the pretty houses lined
up on the street yeah
you have a very beautiful speaking voice
it's like glow
very low in sultry I like it like yeah
very deep I like it
I love it I love it
chew
honey
goes to New York she likes to visit the
MOMA museum oh yeah yeah
all right I love New York
okay don't Mina Mina what about you
she likes shopping and she's eating
Donuts yeah
I love shopping and speaking of outfits
like I don't know who does your wardrobe
or if y'all are involved in that at all
but it's so cool it's like modern
Bridgerton and I'm here for it
so cool I love it is
so cool I'm into it
um
[Music]
so she likes uh gummies in Korean they
call it jellies but gummies like gummy
bears yeah like gummy bears she likes
buying Sour Patch Kids
[Applause]
chocolate covered gummy bears yeah
um
chewy okay wait wait what you is good no
no so you how would how do you say it in
Korean it's chewy how do you want me to
say it
chewy
oh how you say it's adorable
[Applause]
I think I said it right yeah I'm trying
so you're performing your single
Moonlight sunrise today so what's the
song about sunrise
[Music]
foreign
's heart and they use the metaphor of
Moonlight and sunrise to parallel that
fluttering heart feeling when you're in
love oh
[Applause]
and it took me and to y'all because I
was like so used to it from childhood
but then I've I heard that this was
something that y'all kind of had in the
making for a while right yeah what was
what was so important to you to change
it to just the chicks
well I think just after George Floyd and
all of that we wanted to get rid of the
Dixie part of our name for a long time
but it seemed like a huge thing to do so
we would call you know our merch would
say dcx and we always referred to
ourselves as the chicks so it seemed
like a really natural uh change and it
seemed kind of seamless here's what was
cool is you like educated a lot of us as
well because I had no idea that it meant
anything so like I had to like go I was
like wait what and I was like Googling
and it was interesting to find out you
know kind of the origin of that word
like the same I always thought it was a
region like if it's what what direction
me too so it was like it was interesting
though I thought I thought that that was
that was a really cool to educate the
public though on something especially at
such an important time yeah so I thought
it was really cool and also it's just
like easier to say so that's awesome I'm
lazy
um but I love it and then I think
everybody would always say that too oh
did you see the chicks did you see the
concert he'd always call you all that
yeah I think super fans like me
um so what do you each remember from
like the very first time that you all
played together was it like awkward or
like you knew right away it was gonna
work well Natalie had joined the band a
previous lineup and so Marty and I were
very like nervous like well she
rehearsed all the songs and knew all the
songs now he was just like oh I got this
y'all this confidence since Marty and I
are just like oh my gosh oh my gosh but
Natalie brought this humongous pad with
her lyrics on it and we just flip it in
between songs we played these two clubs
in outside of Houston yeah and I would
just
bend down Turn the Page oh my god do you
have a problem with lyrics I do no but I
had to learn 22 songs in seven days I
would just listen with headphones and
and
yet I never yodled before
oh my gosh so the band the band was
famous they had to be reminded of this
the band was famously boycotted on
country radio 19 years ago which feels
like forever ago to me um but it
happened after Natalie you spoke out
against the war in Iraq and the
president in 2003 right so what did you
I ended up it was shut up and sing right
the documentary that came out I loved
that I think a lot of artists or anybody
that's under a microscope
I'm jumping straight to that I'm going
to ask the question but I'm jumping
straight to that because when you're
under a microscope everything you say
even if you don't mean something
somewhere or even if you it's in a
moment everything gets Blended good or
bad and it's a very hard way to live and
especially being in an industry like
I've been told to shut up and sing and
not have an opinion and it's it's very
hard because you're a human and we all
count you know our thoughts and our
hearts count so how did how did y'all
deal with that that had to be hard after
watching that shut up and seeing that
was hard not only on y'all but the
people around you right
yeah I don't know I've I'm a fighter so
I I might crumble
[Applause]
I did crumble like after we won all the
Grammys that kind of fell apart after
that I think I was just like in this
fight mode and then it all sort of Came
Crashing Down it's a lot of weight to
carry yeah yeah and it was for how it
was affecting other people I didn't care
how it was affecting that's what I'm
saying yeah the tour is for your album
gaslighter A lot of people relate to
this album and the message and
um and just I guess from an artist's
point of view like how hard is it asking
for a friend while I'm currently writing
um through a similar situation is how
hard is that to write so openly and so
honest while navigating children while
navigating
people you know you're under a
microscope like there's so much like I
feel like I've written so many songs
myself for my personal like life and I
keep kind of going oh should I do that
or oh God or is that I did you go
through that like while writing this
um I definitely wanted to be very
blatant and like literal with this one
but um yeah I was still I wasn't like
beyond all the emotion like I am now and
then there's a stress of oh my gosh now
my kids are going to hear this and then
yeah now my son is on tour with us he's
in the band and I'm like this is kind of
weird
hahaha
[Applause]
there you go
very awkward yeah but I but I love the
fact that like he's an artist so he does
get the fact that like it's very
therapeutic for us to like that's our
Outlet like that's no way around it when
you write falsely it doesn't work it's
transparently yeah you have to be real
agree sorry I was so blessed it's weird
the more specific you are the more it's
Universal to other people which isn't
I know
I mean life is so hard yeah it's sad
that people relate okay so we all went
through divorces
um and how did you each find strength
and not just music I think it's
therapeutic but like your female
friendships I feel like that has really
helped me yeah I remember you're when
you first came down in the studio in
Nashville and said guys I just want to
tell you I'm getting a divorce which one
was this
I remember thinking well I'm getting a
divorce now she says she's getting a
divorce now I can't say I'm getting a
divorce it was kind but yeah but he's
saying it okay
I was feeling like everybody was going
to judge me because I was like I thought
I was first getting kept that in yeah so
I was like guys I'm getting a divorce
and Mary's like
because I didn't know anybody close to
me that was getting a divorce so it was
I was so happy for it
but it is it is something to talk about
because there is a level of like shame
and like guilt and like and people
especially from where we're from like
it's like you stick it out and it's like
um that's what I've been doing you know
and I don't know if I can do it I don't
know if I can continue that for both of
you like it's like obviously it's not
working you know and people aren't happy
so it's a hard thing I can't imagine
holding that in like I had to like
finally I mean I can't imagine holding
it in for a while and then you finally
say it but the release of that is is so
Monumental I don't know I felt like it
was for me did you oh yeah yeah but I
didn't have kids with that one and she
didn't either and I think it's so much
harder when you've got your babies yeah
it is that's where the decision making
sucks
foreign
I want to say it was in Nashville did
you open for Florence in the machine I
think so it was so amazing I was
literally at the show with a bunch of
friends and I I literally didn't know we
showed up and I was like wait who the
hell is this and y'all are so amazing oh
my gosh thank you so much I am I'm just
I'm so excited to be okay a million
times well I'm freaking out as well I
thought you were so talented I was just
like wow and you also act now
congratulations I didn't know that
random that's amazing crazy um well
what's been the craziest moment like on
stage I've had a lot of crazy ones have
you ever think oh you're absolutely
wrong
um all the time I mean my sister SD can
never you know she trips constantly
always she trips I don't know what a why
but she does there's so many videos in
front of the internet falling but I
think for me
um but by the end of tour like I
remember it was our last show and for
some reason me and my siblings decided
for this whole tour that we were gonna
wear these leather pants which is I
don't if you're ever gonna go on tour
you are not sweating oh schwitzing yeah
to my core yeah and I I really do not
recommend it and these pants were they
had no give and I remember specifically
right before the show because it was our
last show we like packed everything up
and it was like already on the bus so
like I had no other clothes and I don't
know what I did but like I I might have
like got low or something and the back
of my pants just completely split open
this has happened to me no
streaming on music video stop my whole
ass was hanging out oh my God yeah whole
ass not even just a little yeah big old
butt behind yeah just big old behind
yeah it's the craziest feeling okay
there's a draft yeah
exactly there's a draft oh my God I
can't believe that's happened to you oh
yeah you were on stage I was on stage
and because I was like oh okay I'll just
go I'll just like run off stage and then
come back on with like new pants but I
realized that I had packed everything
and it was like far away what did you do
I just kept going and I didn't turn
around my size asses that's not a
possibility for me no I just was like if
I get through this I'll it'll be fine
I'm just gonna get through it but like I
fully I think it was just like I've
never been more stiff in my whole life I
was like holding you're Beyonce you just
keep going like kept going oh my God
going but it was terrible I will never
wear leather pants on but here's the
thing you might have never turned around
but the rest of the band oh yeah they
got a show they got that show they got
the best chicken in the house
so you have a rule when working together
what is it
oh we each have a CBA which we can pull
at any time
it's a can't be our review card and it
we stole it from the national it's
basically like you can't be argued oh
can't be argued you could do this on set
too yeah
veto yeah or we use it the other way
opposite of a veto where it's like this
is my can't be argued this is my thing
that if you take this away from me this
is going to not work for the band like I
need this moment let me get one you get
one get one oh you only get one that's
good we each get one because her album
per day
this is
has there ever been one where the the
other has been like
no really I don't know think this is a
good idea where you you really push you
know you're like come on we're usually
on the same page like when it comes to
Joint decisions like we really are I
don't know why apart and you'd been like
no
you know the only time yes
and then we were like should we tell the
story no but but I do think on this
record there was one song in particular
that stood out to us that I knew was
like this is going on the record yeah
and Ali was like I don't know it's not
like it feels a little bit soft compared
to the other songs it's a little more
gospel leaning but like we also know
that that's kind of where Our Roots came
from so we were like let's honor this
yeah but Ali was like I'm not sure if it
was I don't know guessing it I was like
this is my CBA this song is going on and
thank God because and then and now I
actually I mean I it makes sense that
it's on the record and I I'm glad that
AJ pulled it yeah the CBA out yeah
usually that's all artists do that we
second guess things yeah and you can't
ever predict like what people are gonna
like anyway so you might as well just
pick what you love and put it out
remember if the Beatles would still have
been together if they had a TV there you
go
slightly woman thing
of recognizing someone's and guys I'm
sorry I agree with you
um
and if they had this you know maybe some
of the great bands would still be
together that broke up well maybe we'll
change the history right here
right now you're welcome you're welcome
everyone gets a CBA today yeah
okay what do I do with this I'm gonna
use that with my kids
um so but they're not allowed to have
one
I'm just kidding it's a democracy
um so tell us about the song you're
going to be performing it's called Blue
Dress what's this song about
well when we when we got in to write
music for this new record we for
whatever reason we felt like we were
really connected to like old country
songs at that moment I mean we always
have grown up listening to country music
like The Judds and you know Loretta Lynn
and like these these great country
artists and these songs that have this
incredible storytelling behind them and
we wanted to kind of like encapsulate
that within the song and you know we're
not we're not Legends like them but no
you know they Inspire us yeah and the
storytelling of those artists you just
mentioned too okay so what
start working together because you've
known each other you were friends first
right yeah we went to school together we
were in
um uh what is it called College college
I'm leaving out the community that's
right like when I say that she's like
that
it was College because it's your Basics
out of the way everybody
's upon that so we went to college
together and we also worked at Sears as
telephone solicitors together I got her
a job they were hiring she was like I
want to work at Sears I said they'll
hire anybody
yes and the funny thing about Sears is
Martin Lawrence worked their kids to
play salt and pepper and Herbie Love Bug
our producer and everyone went on to do
what they set out to do yeah
the training ground yeah that's amazing
so did you always know each other and
you always knew that you wanted to be
salt and pepper like you always wanted
to do a group no well we was just as at
college instead of playing cards in a
lunchroom hanging out hanging out and
everything but then out you know Herbie
our producer you know he was going to a
music school at the time so he wanted to
put the group together and so I
auditioned and got it no and I'm like
why are you laughing it's worked out
good thing about salt and pepper is like
we're opposite but we're also very much
alike which is weird and you know how
Opposites Attract I always say the
chemistry between us is she pulls me to
the edge and I keep her from going over
like you know we just heater
what are some like a memorable moment
that you love from your career there's
so many the Grammys the Grammys the
Grammy is one of them because we when we
petitioned it because they weren't doing
you know showing um when you won a award
or you know the Grammys at the time
hip-hop they weren't you know showing it
on television they wouldn't air it and
we so we like petitioning it and
everything and then Will Smith with Will
Smith yeah and then we went on to win
one and it was televised so it was like
oh my God it was a big moment for us for
women in hip-hop
[Applause]
yeah you're like like I know people that
have won Grammys and they're like it
wasn't televised and it was like maybe
their first time to do it it's like oh
man what a bummer like because you as a
kid or like you have that moment you
think of that's gonna happen you know
I'm so glad you got that that's amazing
and you were like we deserve this and
then it happened exactly so I mean you
guys I mean first of all welcome I'm so
excited that you're here
I was saying earlier like all of you are
like musical Inspirations for me like I
and still I still is like literally in
my Spotify playlist is all 90s music so
um because it's the best um but um have
you had a chance though like to people
that you were inspired by like have you
had a chance to like meet with or sing
with like people that really like
inspired you to be who you are
absolutely who are those so many people
early and when we first got in the game
Gladys Knight oh God Patti LaBelle wow
yeah okay so you just like dropped all
the real Jesus the real Divas wow oh my
God Shaka oh so okay so Cindy you you
learned that you could harmonize in a
really unique way when you're a kid
right I did I was six years old it was
to The Bugs Bunny theme with my dad I
didn't know what harmonizing was but he
he said you sing this part I'm gonna
sing this part and and that was
harmonizing I was like Ah that's amazing
I know that you've kept it because
usually kids even though stray to
whatever the other person's singing
That's amazing I just my dad was a
singer and it was just music in the
household all the time my sister so I
just just wow that's beautiful what
about a memorable like early gig for you
a memorable early gig there's got to be
a lot there was this one moment and it
was just so pivotal for us when we
performed with Stevie Wonder What oh my
God all the names you're dropping we
recorded um a song with him called what
the fuss
and
um we were in the studio and when we it
wasn't our first time meeting him but
what was so crazy was when we got there
he called us each of us out by name and
we were looking at each other like how
in the world oh cause he can't oh right
we were like wait can he see
and
we did this other gig and he was there
and why did he we you know we had we
were interacting with each other and why
did he call out our birthdays what years
later okay he was the guy on top of your
bus
[Laughter]
was like
Stevie come on can't you see oh my God
are you lying to me right now you know
what's funny though is like no not you
him like are you like I promise I'm not
lying I have to ask was this all thought
out for the beginning because even how
y'all sing in unison I mean usually
people will double your vocal you know
to have that kind of effect but it's
cool because you have different tones
was it all like set out like that in the
beginning to do the kind of Unison thing
and synchronize thing and then separate
in Harmony and the whole style was that
all from the beginning
well in the beginning I mean basically
we just both wanted to sing lead and we
couldn't decide how are we going to do
this yeah so um you know we were in the
studio we were doing a rearrangement of
a song from The White Album and so we
started both singing at the same time
while our cans were on it was like oh
that's really cool it's like a double
track vocal yeah except we could do this
live how cool and except you have you're
able to blend well but your tones are
slightly different that it makes that oh
yeah magic yeah thank you you know we
like old school
Showmanship and and old school you know
girl groups and people that make a thing
of their their look and dress the sound
yes yeah trying to do something that you
know sort of transports us and
transports our audience and then we got
carried away I love it though like this
whole performance art that's happening
as well with how you perform how you
look like you still keep individuality
but look similar it's very cool I'm just
going to compliment okay the man I'll
never find is the song you're going to
be singing today the whole album mind
you this song is amazing but the whole
album is amazing it's just I
specifically when I heard this song was
going through a really hard time and
divorce and I I don't know if I've wept
like that in a very long time so so I'm
angry about it but also thank you
um but it just it's it's one of those
things I feel is so special and and rare
sometimes because people in this
business and you know they just want you
to do a hit and they want you to like
just do something out that's catchy and
people remember for a minute and
whatever and it's not always long
lasting and I think it's just a great
job of like really being a poet like and
really saying how your heart was and
like it's just the most amazing thing
for us to listen as fans to music and
connect in that way you do an awesome
job of that like have you do you find
yourself to be singers first or writers
because geez it's a hard tug of war
there for me yeah
um yeah I don't know it's it's such a
different headspace I think like yeah
and we're not able to write really on
the road when we're in like tour mode
it's really hard to write some people
are good at that I don't do that yeah
yeah I mean I think it was easy to write
at a time I was going through a divorce
and
um we sat down to right and then
pandemic hit us so we really were gifted
all this time all this time all this
drama all this difficulty honestly that
we could all relate to clearly yeah and
unfortunately yeah unfortunately divorce
is a hit
something out of it
it is hard though to Bear it it's taken
me God I don't even know how many years
it would be since my last like to I had
to tell my label I was like I can't talk
about it yeah like I can't be
interviewed about it yet so like I can't
release the album yet it took me that
long to even say yes to releasing it
like did it take you a minute like when
it's something that personal to like
release it out or is it therapeutic for
you in that sense
it was therapeutic I mean I think it was
difficult to start writing about it and
then once we did
you know she's been we have a unique
thing because we're traveling together
she's seeing my life and I'm seeing hers
we're witnesses to each other's life and
we're songwriting Partners so we're
really able to write on behalf of the
other person yeah in a very you know
sort of special way yeah and so by the
time we sat to write
it was clear
that it was over and yeah you know it
was it was easier to actually just pour
it out and then once you get it out it's
somebody else's you get to give it to
somebody else for whatever it is that
they're gonna how however it is that
they're going to receive it yeah so
that's that's kind of how did you do you
do this thing
um where you write what you really want
to sing and then you have to kind of
filter yourself
to bring that back
that was too much that's what we're for
oh okay yeah I don't have that I'm just
it's just me going was that too I think
it might have been too much I think
that's too much
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
I'm going
[Music]